the coronavirus has upended the world of
higher education in March students were
abruptly sent home classes were moved
online now as campuses across the
country sit empty administrators are
scrambling to prepare for what comes
next in many ways the attack The Cove
addres presents to higher education is a
really straightforward assault on the
bottom line the financial challenges are
severe I mean kids you there they're
profoundly challenging there will be
more bankruptcies more business failures
more need for federal and state bailouts
the pandemic has thrown the budgets of
public and private colleges into turmoil
since the lockdowns wanted to effect
they have seen their revenues drop and
their expenses climb
I think yet more than belt-tightening
this may be something like
reconstructive surgery if not actually
you know thoracic surgery with all
education now virtual elearning is
having a moment when students were sent
home in semester American higher ed
began what was essentially a nationwide
experiment in the space of three weeks
all learning was moved from the
classroom to the internet this is
accelerated the trend towards online
education and raised more fundamental
questions about the value of a college
degree college students suing Drexel
University the University of Miami and
others saying online learning is no
replacement for a bricks and mortar
on-campus experience what will be the
lasting legacy of kovat 19 for higher
education could this virus lead to a
wave of college and university closures
well the classroom we once knew
gradually returned or could Cove it
permanently transform how we learn to
help answer these questions
I spoke to Brian Alexander a higher
education futurist as this title
suggests Alexander spends a lot of time
contemplating what might happen in the
higher education space in a passage
included in his 2020 book Alexander
suggested the possibility of a global
pandemic transforming the industry
I wrote the chapter in 2018 2019 and I'm
afraid it is chillingly oppressions but
how do you imagine a post kovat future
when so little is known about kovat
itself with so much uncertainty
surrounding the pandemic Alexander
believes it's impossible to divine any
one outcome instead he sees three
potential paths for the future of higher
education one is that we could be in the
middle of a short plague and that is
that something which burns out
relatively quickly that perhaps perhaps
a month from now we are very very far
down the downhill side and that come
August and September we'll be in good
shape and colleges and universities can
open their physical doors to welcome
face-to-face students again a second
possibility is that the pandemic will
extend through December into 2021
in that case then we have to think about
higher education being virtual
throughout the entire fall semester
recently the California State University
System announced it will be canceling
most in-person classes in the fall and
will instead hold them online this is
significant because the Cal State System
is the largest four-year university
system in the country the system is also
one of the most diverse in the country
with one third of undergraduates the
first and their families to attend
college one of those is Anna Ruth Burt
ellezi a senior at San Francisco State
University as a single parent oh my son
he's a seventh grader soon now close to
be an eighth grader it was it was a
challenge like many students one
challenge anna has faced our class
disruptions due to a slow internet
connection there's moments when if I ask
a question to my zoom class professor I
either and my voice is not even
projecting or it stops students like
Anna would also be impacted by
Alexander's third forecast third
possibility is that instead of having a
simple pandemic short or long that will
have something more complicated with
multiple waves for academia I dubbed
this the toggle term this is when a
campus will have to switch back and
forth between face-to-face instruction
and holy
my instruction each of these scenarios
would be costly even in the best
forecast where the pandemic is shorter
and campuses reopen in the fall there's
no guarantee that all students and
faculty will return that means smaller
classes and less revenue for schools if
the fall semester is online alexander
expects the financial hit to be even
more severe as more students demand
tuition breaks we have about 4400
college and universities in the u.s. all
told and I could see easily 10% staring
into the abyss this time next year what
worries me are first of all private
colleges and universities that you know
therefore lack any state support but
that are not the most highly ranked the
lower ranked to the media branch once
Dominican University is a small private
liberal arts college located in San
Rafael California yeah we know we're
gonna have some financial hits so we
know we'll have to make some adjustments
to get there but we know where we're
headed and we're really reasonably well
positioned to manage this the place
where Dominican is not as well
positioned and it's true of many many
small colleges is we don't have deep
pockets yeah we have a really small
endowment but small private schools
aren't the only ones at risk some state
universities are in trouble as well I'm
also concerned about public university
systems that are facing similar problems
for example you think about Pennsylvania
one of the public systems at risk is
Pennsylvania's state System of Higher
Education which is made up of 14
state-owned colleges and universities
the challenges of higher education
public higher education generally
they're pretty acutely concentrated here
obviously a historic pattern of
declining public investment has forced
universities to increase tuition and and
actually net average price overall so
those challenges sort of have combined
in our system to produce to 20 percent
enrollment decrease since 2010 between
2010 and 2013 and obviously as our
enrollments go down we're enrollment
driven industry and as a consequence our
revenues have declined as well if there
is one consensus in higher ed it's that
online education is here to stay
and that it will only grow in importance
one company that is uniquely positioned
to understand this trend is check-check
provides online services for about 60%
of American college students when I went
to college many many years ago you know
my intro to business courses were 300
person lectures and a giant auditorium
not only are those potentially dangerous
right now but the reality is those lend
themselves very very well to online
learning last semester
schools were forced online out of
necessity but the reality is for many
students necessity may keep them there
we have to imagine that many many
families are seeing their savings and
investments put into chaos those who
have those some of them are being hit
economically by unemployment or
underemployment some of them
additionally are being hit by disease
like a lot of things right now what
you're seeing is an acceleration there's
already been a movement of lots of
people questioning the ROI of going in
for a 4-year degree that all in May cost
250 or 300 thousand dollars for people
while they're also not working and
getting a job that entire time more
students online means less revenue for
schools but Brian Alexander is
optimistic that the industry will get
creative and adapt to students needs
well for looking at the fall and if
either of my scenarios come to pass
either the toggle term or they long
plagued and faculty and staff have to
prepare for a full semester online now
we have months not weeks we have most a
plan prepare shape and home the
experience